mi maestro me pidió que le ayude a
formar cinco equipos con el mismo número
de integrantes para realizar una
actividad en clase si en total somos 50
en el salón sabes que tengo que hacer
para que cada grupo tenga el mismo
número de personas para conocer cuántas
personas deben de estar en cada equipo
debemos realizar una operación que
seguro ya has escuchado una división te
suena es lo contrario multiplicar y no
es otra cosa más que repartir en partes
o grupos iguales pon mucha atención
escribir en nuestra operación así 50
entre 5 porque entre porque vamos a
dividir los 50 estudiantes que somos en
5 equipos antes de empezar a calcular te
presento los componentes de la división
tienen nombre poco comunes pero es
necesario que los vayas identificando al
5 lo llamaremos divisor porque es quien
va a dividir a otro número al 50 lo
llamamos dividendo porque es quien se va
a dividir
esta línea que separa los números se
llama casilla al resultado lo llamamos
cociente y se escribe arriba y hay un
componente más que aún no aparece pero
en cuanto aparezca te lo presento veamos
esta división hay dos números que son
iguales tenemos un 5 dentro de la
casilla y 1 fuera sólo que el de adentro
está acompañado de un 0 te diré una
forma rápida para resolver este tipo de
operaciones divide únicamente los
números que no son 0 es decir 5 entre 5
busquemos el número que al multiplicarlo
por 5 nos dé 5 se te viene a la mente
alguno claro el 1 ese lo escribimos aquí
1 por 5 igual a 5 para verificar nuestra
multiplicación escribimos el 5 aquí
abajo y restaremos 55 menos 5 igual a
cero
vamos muy bien te acuerdas que hace un
momento te dije que faltaba otro
componente ya lo tenemos es este de aquí
y se llama residuo tal vez te suena
trabalenguas pero es el número o la
cantidad que sobra después de dividir y
en este caso es el cero ahora pasamos al
cero busquemos el número que
multiplicado por cinco
nos dé cero y no hay otro más que cero
cinco por cero es igual a cero lo
escribimos al lado del uno y listo
resolvimos nuestra división quiere decir
que si somos 50 estudiantes en el salón
los cinco equipos se conformarán por
diez estudiantes cada uno para saber si
nuestro resultado es correcto vamos a
multiplicar 5 por 10 nuevamente te darás
cuenta de que si multiplicas 5 por 1 son
5 y sólo hay que aumentar un cero
esta es una manera rápida para dividir y
multiplicar cuando encontramos números
que incluyen uno o más ceros hacemos la
operación con los números que no son
ceros y al final aumentamos la misma
cantidad de ceros veamos otra forma de
dividir te aseguro que te ayudará mucho
acaba de llegar una donación de 146
libros en mi escuela y la directora
quiere repartir los entre los seis
grupos de primaria en este caso qué
número crees que es el que se divide y
cuál dividida
pensemos muy bien si son 146 libros los
que donaron y la directora quiere
repartir los entre los seis grupos 146
será el dividendo y 6 el divisor
entonces escribimos dentro de la casilla
el 146 y el 6 afuera como puedes ver no
tenemos más ceros en esta división pero
te voy a enseñar a resolverla de manera
rápida el primer paso es escribir la
tabla del 6 porque ese es el divisor
multiplicamos el 6 hasta llegar al
número más cercano al 146 que es nuestro
dividendo nos tardaremos mucho no crees
así que vamos a tomar los dos primeros
dígitos es decir 14 6 por 1 igual a 6 6
por 2 igual a 12 6 por 3 es 18 ya nos
pasamos eso quiere decir que el número
que necesitamos para el cociente es el 2
porque 6 por 2 igual a 12 y es el que
está más cerca del 14 escribimos el 2 y
lo multiplicamos por 6
que nos da 12 s 12 lo escribimos debajo
del 14 para arrestarlo entonces 14 12 es
igual a 2 y bajamos el 6 que nos falta
dividir hasta el momento tenemos 26 en
el residuo sigamos con la tabla de
multiplicar hasta encontrar el número
más cercano al 26 estábamos en 6 por 3
igual a 18 6 por 4 igual a 24 por 5 son
30 como el 30 es más grande que 26
entonces el número que necesitamos es el
4 como ya sabemos que 6 por 4 es 24 lo
escribimos debajo del 26 y restamos 26
menos 24 y obtenemos 2 listo terminamos
nuestra operación porque el 2 es más
chico que el 6 y ya no se puede dividir
por lo tanto 2 es nuestro residuo así
podemos decir que a cada grupo le tocan
24 libros y los 2 que sobran se quedarán
en la biblioteca